okay so this video is on the topic of
acid rain so let's go ahead and get
started well before we get into what is
acid rain let's examine this picture you
might recognize this as the pH scale and
what the pH scale measures is the amount
of hydrogen ions within a solution you
might know that anything below a seven
on the pH scale is categorized as an
acid acids tend to have more hydrogen
ions so the farther to the left you go a
solution with a for-instance ph one will
have more hydrogen ions than a solution
with a pH five and then above a seven
you have the realm of the bases and
bases tend to have very few hydrogen
ions so a solution with a pH of 12 will
have less hydrogen ions than a solution
with a pH of of eight well when we
examine rain water naturally rain water
if you examine the pH of normal
rainwater it's in the realm of the very
weak acids about a five point six you
know seven is a neutral solution so five
point six is pretty close to neutral
seven but it's still within the range of
the acids well why is rainwater
naturally an acid with a pH of five
point six well that's because there's
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere and
when it rains the carbon dioxide mixes
with rainwater to make
carbonic acid and these are the carbonic
acid falls to the ground and it's in the
rivers and the lakes and the streams and
it's absorbed into the soil and so this
is why however the natural pH of
rainwater is in the five point six
acidic range because of the carbon
dioxide in the air
well if we come back to our pH scale and
we examine it so then what is acid rain
well it's precipitation with a pH below
the normal of five point six and usually
we see acid range in the realms of the
low fours
you know 4.1 4.2 4.3 but rainwater
precipitation with a pH below the normal
of 5.6 is generally what we consider to
be acid rain and so what is the cause of
acid rain well it really comes from you
know these two gases that are released
into the atmosphere so2 is the symbol
for sulfur dioxide and then NOx and Oh X
is the symbol for nitrogen oxides these
tend to be in the app guesses are
released into the atmosphere and when
they're in the atmosphere they tend to
react with rainwater whenever it rains
and when when these gases react with
rainwater they turn into sulfuric acid
and nitric acid and of course as it
continues to rain these acids get
basically washed down to the surface
down to the ground and they mix in
rivers and lakes and streams and they
absorb into the soil of the earth so
where do these sulfur dioxides and
nitrogen oxides that are in the
atmosphere come from well a natural
source would be volcanoes you know when
volcanoes erupt these are some of the
gas gases that are released into the
atmosphere as the volcano erupts but I
think the reason we're watching this
video is to try to understand the
man-made causes of acid rain and we see
it in the burning of fossil fuels now in
this picture here of an of a tailpipe of
the exhaust pipe of the automobile that
dioxis all four die oxides and nitrogen
oxides are released in the exhaust of
automobiles and there's a lot of
automobiles spread throughout the world
of course well not only is sulfur
dioxides
and nitrogen oxides released from
automobiles but also in
the reason industries around the world
when fossil fuels are burned usually in
the production of electricity and in
power to keep industry and factories
running but the the exhaust as you see
in this animation here tends to release
a lot of sulfur dioxides and nitrogen
oxides into the atmosphere and so what
are some effects of acid rain in nature
well number one it makes ecosystems more
acidic so as it rains you know the acids
you know wash into the rivers and in the
lakes and the ponds and are absorbed
into the soil of ecosystems around the
world
so as the pH is lowered into the harmful
acidic range this tends to hurt and harm
aquatic organisms such as fish
crustaceans and plankton that might
survive in these waterways and you know
here's some images of some you know dead
fish washed up because they were unable
to survive in the areas that were
affected most their habitat let's not
forget about the effects that this might
have on terrestrial life life that lives
on land as the pH of the soil is lowered
you know trees absorb these acids and
effects and phibian in the crop the
health of crops that are living within
the trying to be grown within an area
you know here we see some trees that
were harmed and damaged you can see the
trees are basically dead as they
absorbed the acids from the acid rain
you know there have been all kinds of
studies that have been done where crops
have been grown in areas with a lower
soil PH and the crops just generally
don't grow as well and therefore the
crop yield is much less and this could
harm of course you know the economic
benefits of that farmers enjoy when when
they grow their crops
and so how can acid rain be reduced well
well one of the things that we're seeing
is finding your figured out ways is to
neutralize the acidic soil and the
acidic waters of these ecosystems that
are affected the most and this picture
shows an act called Lyman where crushed
limestone is added to acidic soil in
this picture acidic soil and also in
acidic water ways to help help raise the
pH back to its normal level now this is
obviously only a temporary solution
because if acid rain continues in these
areas then liming will need to be
continued as well but limestone is helps
to counteract and bring up the pH to a
more healthy healthy range technology
has been used to help remove pollutants
from the air here we're looking at the
underside of an automobile at the
catalytic converter catalytic converters
will chemically change the exhaust of
the pollutants found in the exhaust of
automobiles at how it chemically changes
them into less harmful molecules also
industries in many cases have what are
called scrubbers on them and the
scrubber will remove pollutants from
industrial exhaust so as the exhaust
enters the scrubber the black dots are
representing of the pollutants the
pollutants are being basically filtered
out and when the exhaust comes out the
top end the pollutants have been removed
and so therefore the exhaust is a little
cleaner as it is released into the air
and into the ecosystem and let's not
forget well if burning fossil fuels is
one of the you know man-made causes of
acid rain then figuring out ways to
reduce our fossil fuel usage needs to be
explored coal oil natural gas for
they're not ways to become less
dependent upon these and so as we
explore alternative energy such as wind
energy and such as solar energy these
are ways that can hopefully limit the
use of fossil fuels as we try to produce
energy for our you know modern way of
life you know automobiles today are
becoming more fuel efficient not only
that but trying to refigure out ways to
you know become less dependent on them
such as carpooling and biking and more
fuel-efficient automobiles and public
transportation anything that we can do
to take some automobiles off of the road
should be viewed as a positive step
so for serious about reducing acid rain
then we really need to examine our
ability to reduce energy consumption
while at home and that would you know
require using more products that are
Energy Star labeled as they require less
power to be operated you know compact
fluorescent light bulbs use less energy
and therefore again reduce our use of
fossil fuels you know we're all guilty
from time to time of opening the
refrigerator door and staring into the
refrigerator and letting out the cool
energy but at the cool temperature but
when we do that it's a really poor use
of electricity and trying to avoid
situations like this you know also
trying to avoid those long 15 20 minute
hot showers that might feel really nice
in the winter but it takes a lot of
energy from your water heater to warm up
that hot water and this would be viewed
as very wasteful you know in the summer
times when we use our air conditioner 7
the temperature around 78 degrees should
be viewed I'm hoping as a comfortable
range where we're not being too wasteful
and lastly just turning things off when
we are done turning off the lights
turning off the TV turning off the
computers anything that we can do to
limit our use of fossil fuels should be
viewed as a positive step in reducing
acid rain
so there you have it there's the end of
our video on acid rain please if you're
in my class you know answer these
questions on a separate sheet of paper
I'd be happy to check your answers
before or after school one day and leave
your comments in the box below I'd like
to hear what you thought after watching
this video thanks for watching